the hardest part about change is not
making the same choices you did the day
before period and the moment you decide
to make a different Choice get ready
because it's going to feel uncomfortable
Dr Joe dispenza applies quantum physics
to help people make long-lasting change
whether you're trying to break old
habits or make new ones his techniques
transforms people's lives much faster
than traditional methods today I'll
break down the technical aspects of his
work to help you understand the quantum
physics and Neuroscience behind his
revolutionary work of breaking the habit
of being yourself once you understand
these big Ideas it'll unlock your mind
and help you achieve the full potential
that you know you're capable of just
like the title of his book become
Supernatural he holds a Bachelor of
Science degree and is a doctor of
Chiropractic his postgraduate training
includes the fields of Neuroscience and
epigenetics he's a researcher lecturer
author and corporate consultant do you
believe that the way you think has some
effect on your life I know that some of
you aren't 100 convinced because if you
knew that it was absolutely true you
wouldn't let any thoughts slip by your
awareness that you don't want to
experience you would create the most
detailed map of your future in your mind
you wouldn't miss a day of thinking and
planning it would be the most important
practice of your day Dr Joe dispenza
says that your personality is your
personal reality your personality is
made up of three things your thoughts
your actions and your feelings or you
can say think do and be this is how most
people go about making changes in their
lives they think about something they
want then they go out and do it and then
they'll finally be different let's use
the example of health and fitness people
first start by thinking of all the
reasons why they want to get fit and
healthy thinking about their diet and
thinking about going to the gym and
exercise routines then they go out and
they do it by going to the gym and
working out they buy healthy foods and
cook healthy meals and finally they'll
become the healthy person this is a
traditional logic model for creating and
forming new habits it can work but is
often a much slower process before we
can discuss the spenza's approach to
change we must first understand some
Neuroscience you literally have three
brains that allow you to go from
thinking to doing to being so let's
start off with your first brain called
your neocortex the thinking brain it's
the frontal lobe this is the biggest
piece of your brain it's the most
developed part it's the biggest in
humans and other animals have a much
smaller neocortex like dogs and cats
this is also where your conscious mind
resides you watching this video is using
your frontal lobe to process this
information human beings because of the
size of the neocortex we can turn on the
stress response just by thought along
let's think about our problems and turn
on those chemicals
that means then our thoughts could make
us sick so if it's possible that our
thoughts could make us sick is it
possible then our thoughts could make us
well the answer is absolutely yes the
second is the limbic brain this is the
emotional Center of your brain it
manufactures chemicals and these
chemicals are our feelings and emotions
if you want to start feeling unlimited
abundant or free this is where you begin
the process of changing your genetic
Destiny by signaling new genes in new
ways it regulates the internal chemical
order these chemicals determine how we
feel from moment to moment it's involved
in our behavioral and emotional
responses this is where you train your
body chemically to understand what your
mind has always understood your limbic
brain regulates and makes these
chemicals so that your body becomes
chemically instructed to understand what
your mind has intellectually understood
this is why it's related to doing
because this is where your body is
forced into taking action and finally
there's a cerebellum it's the acting
brain this is the most primitive part of
our brain often referred to as our
Reptilian Brain dispenza calls this the
seat of the subconscious mind our
impulses and habits come from here the
cerebellum is the part of the brain
that's responsible for your implicit
memories this is information you can
recall unconsciously and effortlessly
when you've done something so many times
that you no longer have to consciously
think about it this makes up 95 percent
of your thoughts essentially this is who
you are it's your being most of our
day-to-day thoughts are generated here
in the subconscious with these automatic
thought patterns like your morning
routine when you stumble out of bed
brush your teeth and make your breakfast
taking that same route to work every day
doing the same repetitive tasks at your
job these are all automatic routines
that you don't even have to think about
95 of your thoughts today were the same
as yesterday and the day before that you
have sixty thousand thoughts a day and
the majority of them are the same every
day and these are coming from your
subconscious brain the cerebellum so now
that we understand the different parts
of your brain let's layer on the physics
Concepts that Dr jota spenza teaches on
top of what we just went over I know
this might get a bit technical with all
the science but stick with me I promise
it'll be worth it because this is some
life-changing stuff it takes traditional
methods of habit change and flips it
upside down so following the same model
thinking doing being when we applied it
to health and fitness it was thinking
about our diets and thinking about going
to the gym then to doing going to the
gym working out and buying healthy foods
and finally becoming healthy and fit
this model follows the Newtonian model
of physics which in the most basic term
States what can only be weighed and
measured is true which is great for
examine the predictable it's the model
of cause and effect it means that
something outside of ourselves has to
happen for us to internally feel good
that outside factor is determine our
success the Newtonian model implies lies
that our mind has no control over matter
this was the predominant way of thinking
for hundreds of years until Einstein
ushered in a new era of quantum physics
I want to keep this as simple as
possible because quantum physics is very
complicated it's a study of matter and
energy to examine it at the atomic and
subatomic levels when looking at those
tiny atoms at the quantum level matter
behaves differently depending on whether
we're observing them or not when
scientists are looking to measure atoms
they behave differently when being
watched meaning they are predictable in
one moment they're moving like a wave
but when they're being observed now they
turn into a particle this is called the
observer effect which happens at the
quantum level the act of observing will
change the behavior of things isn't that
just fascinating that matter everything
that we're made of behaves differently
when it's being watched so this tells us
mind is affecting matter it's
scientifically proven that tiny atoms in
energy can be changed by our minds Dr
Joe dispens method teaches us how to
create change in our life the faster way
by unlocking the power of the mind and
it's all backed by science he shows
brain scans and charts the brainwaves of
his patients when their brains are
creating new neural networks and
rewiring their brains his teachings
apply the quantum model for making
changes in our lives remember the
Newtonian method is the older slower way
when you try to think happy thoughts you
read dozens of books on happiness and
learn about the signs of happiness I
know you've all seen it before where
people are trying to overthink their way
through a problem spend all the
resources of their conscious mind trying
to logically think their way to a
solution then you go out and try to do
things that will make you happy days
upon days over analyzing the situation
and eventually if they're lucky might
get to where they want to be or worst
case nothing happens we flip that upside
down when applying the quantum model you
become what you want then you do and
finally your thoughts and thinking
change it's like that saying act as if
or fake it till you make it what's
inside of you represents what's on the
outside so first we must change
internally before we can see any change
on the outside as an example applying
this model to happiness you must first
become happy then you'll do happy things
and finally you'll think happy thoughts
this Quantum model is changing what's on
the inside first so you must be happy
internally and then your life on the
outside will match it's much quicker
than the Newtonian model it might not
seem like it at first glance but the
quantum method is actually what's most
natural to humans if you look at
children they're always happy in their
own little world they don't think about
being happy and try to go out of their
way to seek things to make them happy
children are just being happy their
internal State represents what's on the
outside it's what's most natural to them
it's like that famous quote from Wayne
Dyer when you change the way you look at
things the things you look at change if
you believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking by very definition of
emotions you're thinking in the past and
for the most part you're going to keep
creating the same life what do you call
something that you've done so many times
that your body knows how to do it better
than your mind yeah that's right I have
it well a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition according to Dr Joe dispenza
95 of Who We Are by the time we're 35
years old is a memorized set of
behaviors emotions reactions unconscious
habits hardwired attitudes beliefs and
perceptions that function like a
computer program this means that 95 of
the time we're running on autopilot our
subconscious mind is just running us
through our daily routine and only five
percent is our conscious thoughts then
person can say with their five percent
of their conscious mind I want to be
healthy I want to be happy I want to be
free but the body's on a whole different
program so then how do you begin to make
the those changes well
you have to get beyond the analytical
mind because what separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind is the analytical mind and that's
where meditation comes in do you want to
make a long lasting change in your life
most people try to brute force their way
with conscious thoughts alone but that's
only accessing five percent of our brain
the neocortex that's using the Newtonian
approach but what if you could use the
95 the subconscious mind this is the
Quantum way of making habit change
recall how we discussed the three parts
of the brain the neocortex limbic and
cerebellum which was linked to think do
and be to tap into our cerebellum the
seat of our subconscious mind we do this
through meditation while we're in a deep
meditative State we slow down our brain
waves that's how we enter the
subconscious mind if we think of the
brain as a computer we can enter its
operating system to make really
important changes through meditation and
that's how we access 95 of our brain
your subconscious is the most primitive
part of the brain it doesn't know the
difference between a real life
experience and thoughts in the mind this
is Amplified through meditation when you
suppress the activity in your conscious
mind by slowing down the brain waves if
you focus on creating the future and
anchoring those thoughts to strong
emotions your subconscious mind can't
separate what you're imagining to an
experience in the 3D World we notice
that if we could teach people how to
dial down they're thinking neocortex
their analytical mind
and by sensing space if you're sensing
you're not thinking or analyzing or
sensing and you start slowing your brain
waves from that high beta brainwave
State when you're in survival into these
lower beta brainwave States and
ultimately into Alpha okay Alpha now
Alpha is the creative state Alpha is the
imaginary State that's when the voice in
your head that's talking to you all the
time that default mode kind of shuts off
and your brain starts to see in images
and pictures you start you start
imagining it's an imaginary State it's a
creative state
so we use that state in the state of
creation but then we took it a little
further what if we could teach a person
to slow their brain waves down even more
into Theta and in Theta you're in a
hypnotic state in the hypnotic States
cause you to be very suggestible to
information and suggestibility is your
ability to accept believe and surrender
to information as the truth without ever
analyzing it and that's what exactly
programs the subconscious mind so
through the process of rehearsing your
ideal outcomes over and over in your
head you begin to install the
neurological Hardware into your brain
over time these nerve connections form
and your brain physically changes to
look like the event has already happened
this is how you create a map to your
future we apply the quantum model to our
habits by becoming the change that we
want to see in our lives this is why you
must change internally before seeing
change on the outside when starting a
new habit the nerve cells in our brain
form a connection learning is making
these nerve Connections in your your
brain and memory is retaining them as
these nerve cells communicate with each
other they fire together and wire
together your brain physically changes
when you learn and form new habits
communicating with your brain is like
communicating with anything else it's a
relationship the more you communicate
with someone the more bondage you become
to that person so you should spend more
time communicating with yourself create
what your future should look like in
your mind the more you practice this the
closer you'll get to the Future you've
already created this is why you must
practice your meditation every single
day I want you to act on this
information today so I'll leave you with
this message from Joe dispenser all you
had to do is work on regulating your
internal state every day and the novice
meditators people who just came to an
event that really had no experience in
meditation but immerse themselves for
seven days okay our data suggests at the
end of seven days their body completely
looks like they're in a different life
to get some more incredible jota spenza
motivation check it video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there hey everybody Dr Joe here little
tip for you to change is to be greater
than your environment that means be
greater than the conditions in your life
to be greater than the circumstances in
your world and every great person in
history knew this